welcome ricardo chavetta
[Applause]
oh my goodness i wanted to get the exact
pronunciation right
um i can't believe i'm seeing you
again in this context who would have
ever thought we'd be here
i know i know ricardo i'm so excited to
see you i had so much fun getting to
work with you on santa clarita what a
wild
ride that was and really it was you and
i
that kind of like with tim oliphant
who's the greatest
just kind of really established this
wild world it was
such a unique experience it was such a
rare
weird tone we were trying to pull off
and i loved getting to do it with you
you know i mean and i also i mean
richard t jones and mary elizabeth ellis
joya zmansky you also had some great
guest
guest star actors in that first season
nathan fillion who i know very well
yeah and alan tudya who have been a huge
fan of for a long time
yeah you really you really got some
wonderful actors to come in
and fill out that first season um and
you yourself of course and timothy yeah
well i have to say that selena
the series i i started watching it
because i thought i'm just gonna watch
you know at least the first episode in
anticipation of our conversation i could
not i stayed up till 11 o'clock
i just wait i go to sleep at eight i
could not stop
binging it first of all i really want to
hand it to you
because i have this whole thing about
internal acting and how
irritating boring and sleepy it can be
for people watching because you're like
you're not giving me anything your face
the way your subtlety i feel like the
pathos and everything you're feeling i
think you're acting is so
incredible and i just feel
everything you're feeling and yet you
pulled it off with such nuance and
subtlety how did you do that
wow well hey first off thank you that's
very very kind
um you know i i just i really did my
work
uh this story is very specific to me
because i'm from south texas
yeah uh you know selena and i were born
the same year about four months apart
uh her father is a specific a certain
man of a
certain age and generation that is
specific to south texas
that is my father and a lot of my uncles
my theos as well
so i had a lot of resources to be able
to draw from to try and
you know when i was approaching this
character and how i was going to
represent him
uh and and i utilized as much of that as
possible and also watching the old clips
of abraham and studying his
his cadences and his you know the his
mannerisms his facial
tics and everything so i you know just
and kind of recreating that recreating
and recreating that on my own
so that when i did get to set finally it
was it was kind of second nature
so i didn't have to think about those
things too much and i could focus on
just like
you know giving the dialogue back and
forth and where were we in the emotional
state or whatever that scene was
that makes perfect sense because i think
when you work
so hard at something that's when you can
let go and have fun nobody wants to get
to a test
that they haven't studied for it's
you're not going to perform well and
you're just going to have a ton of
anxiety so all of that work that you did
really pays off i mean you should win
every award for your performance really
i was blown away i just kept going
i can't wait to talk to him he's so good
in this it doesn't stop
it just keeps going going now ricardo
i'm in the kitchen
because i believe you have a cookbook
for cookbook club
i do i actually have two for you i'm a
huge i do a lot of barbecuing
um i barbecued a lot uh when i was
working on selena for
for my cast um so and this is it's kind
of a there's two
it's a generic cookbook uh just on
barbecuing to kind of tone down my
my manly barbecuing that i guess my uh
my family would say
um yeah so cool i love bbq and we
haven't gotten that yet so thank you
that's a new
addition to our collection but the other
book is it's a restaurant that's
familiar to new york that i got and i'm
still working
with it and it's this one bokeh oh yes
yeah yeah so and they do a lot of
cooking a la plancha
and paella yeah yeah so
that's what i'm starting to kind of work
on right now thank you ricardo we'll
have those
up on our website right next to your
name
selena part one of the series is
available now
on netflix once you press play you will
be up all night because you won't be
able to tear yourself away and so much
of that
is due to your extraordinary performance
ricardo
congratulations on this extraordinary
work
and telling the story of someone so
beloved and that's why
it's such a success it's so on trend
everybody's talking about this so
thank you for bringing it to everyone
[Music]
you